not when it killed another human yeah
that's crazy 14. it's kind of weak wait
how old was he 14. kind of weak right
[Music]
all right class all right classroom we
have another photo to show
anybody seen these Packy is that one
chip it is the one chip what do you know
about what do you know about Nick it's
probably gives you diarrhea and it's
probably not that fun to do challenge
it's horrifying okay it says one chip
challenge and it's 6.99 here in this
particular establishment really hot is
it literally just one chip one you
haven't seen this yes all right it's six
bucks
but it's the experience yeah okay so the
point is they just like mix certain
spices and stuff like that and chilies
to make it the most spicy [__] chip
out there so it's a one chip challenge
can you even eat one chip right well
unfortunately someone died it has
claimed the life of a 14 year old boy
from Massachusetts Massachusetts
surprises doesn't happen more often
honestly sure I'm surprised too because
it's like oval units on it like it's
like I'll tell you in just a second yeah
um this particular chip uh concoction
was made of two of the world's hottest
Peppers the Carolina Reaper and the Naga
Viper the Naga Viper I've never heard of
that Carolina Reapers are crazy though I
had one it's crazy that they could sell
that um yeah this is wild to me isn't
that wild okay so in 2022 the Carolina
Reaper and Trinidad Scorpion Chili
Peppers brought uh the burn to this
particular chip challenge and then the
uh this year the Scorpion was swapped
out for the Naga Viper which is a pepper
that was briefly declared the world's
hottest in 2011. okay now when you're
talking about the uh Scoville heat units
uh Shu an extract from a common jalapeno
pepper just for context tops out at 10
000 uh Shu and uh that's the
standardized measurement and regular
jalapeno peppers are are relatively in
the mild 2008 000 for what we normally
have right California Reapers hold the
current world record for exceeding 2
million whoa and the Naga Viper Says
close to around 1.4 million so Carolina
Reaper's still more yeah that's the
record right now so so regular jalapeno
can be 10 000 or less
and we're talking about two million yeah
that's insane hey what did we eat was it
Carolina Reaper and something else is it
ghost pepper I think it was Ghost Pepper
but after that we ate a jalapeno and a
jalapeno tastes like a bell pepper it
just it was it wasn't even hot yeah
that's wild could Indian people eat that
[__] no they don't even it doesn't even
bat an eye
don't you feel like Thai people have
crazier spices oh the chai chilies
they're small but Indian spicy is
definitely strong but I feel like Thai
[__] has [__] me up before yeah you
have to like condition your taste buds
to being used to having such spicy foods
but I do would be watching Indian food
food vendor videos all over I don't know
why they keep popping up but bro I'm
like y'all could eat anything and you'll
survive yeah like don't just [__] be
making fruit juices with their feet
[__] like flies everywhere man it's
crazy you guys know the videos I'm
talking about you know humans were
supposed to actually like like we're
we're adapting to that like when babies
eat like dirt and sand they they eat it
with their feet too no like not no more
like babies they'll like put [__] in
their mouth it actually like conditions
their body like yeah you put in the
bacteria and stuff yeah so then you grow
up and then you become a germaphobe and
then you become weak as [__] yeah I'm
allergic to peanuts now sanitizer [__]
that's the worst dude yeah but that man
I'll be seeing I'm like dang dude y'all
just made [__] curry with the same
bottle that you were just doing dishes
with oh my wow and then I'm just like
and everyone's just eating it yeah so I
had one of these chips I didn't eat it
but we just opened the package
and our eyes started to water oh no I
wanted to do the challenge so did
everyone was like no we're not yeah yeah
well we were gonna have somebody do it
as soon as we opened the package I was
like it's like tear gas it's so hot I've
seen people do it your tongue get blue
yeah it's it's like whatever you're not
down to do it [__] no what's the what's
blue I mix it blue I don't know the
blood running away from your [__]
tongue to like fighting horror poison to
your body yeah everyone just screamed
before they do it we did a lot of spicy
challenges in our day I think we
probably if JK party was going on right
now I think we would have done it we
were trying to take bets like people are
like offering money was on the table
like okay I'll give somebody a hundred
bucks to do it and we kept raising
really we're using the BET to see who
would do it I would have done it after
and then somebody agreed to like I think
it was like 1800 or something and so as
soon as he opened up the bag he was like
nah
y'all should try the the hot ones though
like the wings the hot ones like those
are those are fun I think the difference
with that though is that it's a gradual
thing right so you start to see where
your relativity we're like I'm tapping
out at this level because you started a
mile this is like the hottest [__]
world record pepper you only get one
shot the second you go there it's like
Homer Simpson when you [__] put the
candle wax on this tongue yeah we got
that thing up there I don't know what
that is but that [__] was crazy [__]
it's a little bottle you see that glass
bottle right there yeah yeah what is
that potion you put one drop it [__] how
old is that is that expired it's
probably old I don't think you can
expire probably kills every [__]
bacteria that comes near oh it's been
around where did you get it where'd you
get it I forgot you want to try it no
not if it's been around for five years
come on guys it kills time
Nick says 1800 for you to try it out of
Nick's pocket yeah I'm gonna clean his
pocket no no you said it I don't got I
don't got a Pockets I would be curious
if like if this was the size of the chip
that's a big chip I would be curious to
like
and like try that yeah because the
challenge is you have to do the whole
chip right yeah I'm gonna [__] do
that not when it killed another human
yeah that's crazy 14. it's kind of weak
wait how old was he 14. kind of weak
right that's [__] I'm surprised it
hasn't happened yet yeah are they suing
what's up what's going on with it
especially with everything that people
are allergic to it's like I only I don't
understand how it's legal to sell it's
supposed to be [__] Miners and [__]
the uh the chip company has issued a
statement expressing condolences
withholding further comment but the
product is reportedly being removed from
store shelves in the U.S following the
incident they should have used this and
been like so strong it could kill you it
will kill you yeah the chip challenge
will you survive so what does somebody
die from when they have something that's
way too spicy for them I think it's like
you can't breathe oh really I think like
it gets to that point yeah you can get
to that point so from Suffocation well
if it's a allergic reaction yeah I'm not
I'm not entirely sure what his case so
like the concept right is like it
technically spices meant to fool your
mouth and digest attract into thinking
it's on fire so it triggers A Rush of
excitement in the form of feel-good
hormones so the body's way of motivating
stuff to look beyond the pain and flee
from Raging Fire so the body's preparing
for itself to be hurt so it needs to fix
it right away therefore inflammatory
responses Kickstart healing opens blood
vessels to help cool vital organs and it
forces the digestive tract to release
its content so like that's the concept
of what happens right yeah so in extreme
cases uh that's when people start
[__] sweating like crazy they're like
they can't handle it because they can
die from just do you have
yeah uh cerebral arteries start to get
narrowed uh damage to the esophage
esophagus can happen with repeated
wretching and then obviously death
happens as well oh that sucks that's how
you went out from a chip that sucks bro
yeah that would be the worst to just be
like you just as your kid died from
eating a [__] spicy chip that was
sold for 6.99 publicly no that's nuts
what are we doing where's this country
going and this the single chip being
sold it comes in a coffin Shaped Box
adorned with a red skull complete with a
list of warnings cautioning those who
are pregnant or have medical conditions
against eating the content did he have a
medical condition he's pregnant ah I
mean he was reportedly a healthy
adolescent with no medical conditions so
the team pregnancy though dude you just
never know get you dude he was uh
apparently he out shortly after eating
the Chip he visited his school nurse
complaining of stomach pain at school
yeah it's probably a little challenge
within hours of being sent home he
passed out and stopped breathing and he
was later pronounced dead
yo when you eat something so spicy
though it takes so much energy you do
pass out I remember after we did the uh
care Carolina Reaper challenge or
whatever
it was it was it like exhausted me that
I had to take a nap and I fell asleep
like this and I woke up and half my face
was burning because of the chili that I
touched like
yeah it just burnt from that yeah no
more spicy anything challenges bro do
you guys like spicy food though
I like a medium yeah like halfway I like
spicy can you do like a raw jalapeno
like chew on that while you eat your
food yeah but I'm not taking half at a
time like like when you get far right
they give you a couple slices yeah yeah
I I bite bits off at a time because I
like the rush while I'm eating but I'm
not trying to no like be uncomfortable
yeah yeah no I I just do Sriracha that's
your highest level of spice Sriracha for
it for like oh this is for like
enjoyment yes because I remember in high
school I don't need a [__] like
yeah in high school I used to like the
like yeah I used to like that in high
school that's too much [__] for me this
[__] the hot and spicy that got me
you like that [__] yeah I like Takis do
you go like this I don't go like that
but it just kicks harder and what about
later you get diarrhea uh if I eat the
whole bag in one sitting sure you eat
regular Cheetos you get diarrhea you
know what I like um is Sichuan spicy oh
yeah it's spicy it's not but it is like
oh I can't taste my tongue anymore there
are some when you get those hot pots
that like they when they go ham on that
ghost pepper that [__] bites the one
thing I don't like about eating too much
spicy food is yeah for this [__] yeah
that's who obviously the diarrhea is not
that good um I don't even like
turbulence but the when you start eating
and you start sweating you feel like a
total [__] you feel like uh okay you
don't like that yeah bro I'm just like
pores are coming like sweat's coming out
of my I like a spice that makes me sweat
even though I hate sweating I hate
sweating while I eat I just like that
level of spice I think it depends I
don't want to sweat it is though too
yeah yeah y'all had the spicy Ramen
challenge yeah yeah yeah those those are
it's pretty hardcore yeah
noodles